hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 18th of gene today and you would she
need in two games but news III is
officially all wrapped up with shipped
ourselves back into the Australian time
zone and I'm weaning myself off that
American accent I picked up from
Marrakech and Chris what is let's get
going so in truth we had a bit of a
gaming personality type opinions and
save stuff today but fortunately the
stuff they said it's like some pretty
interesting conversations including one
about whether youtubers are game devs a
bunch of money the word came straight
from the fish's mouth this time Phil
fish that is cementing his reputation
for being very outspoken on his views on
the industry and the harassment of
depths from gamers the first creator
said that youtubers who are using game
footage and making money off set footage
should be sharing that ad revenue with
the game creators through a series of
tweets fish said this should be built
into YouTube anything else is basically
piracy and if you generate money from
putting my content on your channel you
owe me money simple as that this has
made one particular comparison which
seems to be hitting home for some gamers
by claiming if you buy a movie are you
then allowed to stream the entirety of
it publicly for people to watch for free
no because that's illegal saying that
the relationship between YouTube lets
players and game creators can be
somewhat tenuous is definitely an
understatement however let me know if
you see any sense in fishers comments
and why or why not now for some last gen
console news marks after said they
reckon they're still set to sell
millions more xbox 360's thus far the
company have been able to shift 84
million of the buggers to date but
xboxes Phil Spencer has said it won't
stop they're telling British
entertainment site Metro if you bought
your xbox 360 a year and a half ago I
think we have an obligation there we're
going to sell millions more xbox 360's
before this generation is done and when
people make a monetary commitment to us
they're gonna come in and buy an xbox
360 I want to make sure that there's
content for them he cited the reason for
some big games skipping last gen as an
investment in the new generation of
consoles but that they're totally set to
maintain the healthy lineup of software
on
60 humping over to the other side of the
console war fence playstation big dog
Shuhei Yoshida has explained why we
haven't seen some promise ps4 features
appear just yet sad features include the
suspend resume mode which preserves your
game session while using much less power
as well as functionality which was going
to allow another player to virtually
take over your game through the internet
to help you through a level Yoshida has
said our team has been working on it
there are some things that we announced
in February of last year that were not
planned for the launch time frame it's
not ready yet next up you really do need
to watch this gta5 PlayStation 3 of us
is PlayStation 4 trailer comparison
digital foundry have broken down the
differences between each version and the
upcoming new generation issue of the
open-world action game looks really
sweet it's awesome to see rock stars
next gen promises with GTA 5 graphical
improvements including increased draw
distances better resolution and new
wildlife coming to fruition and this is
the best place to check it out for
yourself I'm gonna stop talking just
give it a look be sure to let me know in
that comment box whether you're gonna
pick up GTA 5 again all for the first
time on xbox one ps4 or pc personally
I'm pretty inclined to grab the pc one
at this stage you can also catch me on
my Twitter where I'm at just McDonald
that is it for me today but I will be
back with GS news every day for the rest
of this weekend potentially eternity so
be sure you know that just like winter
GS news is coming I may be having game
of thrones withdrawal but any case i'll
see them were